it's great to welcome to the program
today Josh Douglas who's a law professor
at the University of Kentucky and also
author of the book vote for us how to
take back our elections and change the
future of voting great to talk to you
first and foremost thanks David thanks
for having me on so we could start this
conversation a few different ways I mean
I think for my audience
they're mostly familiar with the
different ways that we've seen mostly
the Republican Party attempt to make it
more difficult to vote this includes
reducing voting hours reducing polling
locations putting in place so-called
voter ID laws gerrymandering I mean that
we could go on and on and on but I think
in the interest of sort of having a
optimistic a conversation as possible
you identify a bunch of different ways
in the book that we can increase voter
access and turnout which i think is a
worthy goal and I think most people in
the audience agree what some of the
lowest hanging fruit to start with that
might immediately give us some positive
results well probably automatic voter
registration is in some ways the lowest
hanging fruit because it's already been
passed in over a dozen states and this
is where the state takes responsibility
of registering everyone using the
information it already has through DMV
offices or what-have-you and essentially
the voter registration lists and the DMV
list talk to each other I say this is
the low-hanging fruit again because
we've seen success and both so-called
bred and so-called blue states that have
adopted this reform and when we talk
about automatic registration there's a
couple of different ways I've seen at
work one is when there is some other
kind of interaction with a sort of
government system whether you are
renewing your license or you are turning
18 or sort of some other ways what are
the different ways that this could
actually happen and is there some way
that doesn't involve any kind of
interaction it's simply when you move in
some place and change your address
you're immediately registered to vote
yes so the requirement that you be given
the opportunity to register to vote
already exists under federal law this is
the motor voter in law that says any
time you interact with
mental entity like the DMV office they
give you the opportunity to register
what automatic voter registration does
is takes that step of opting in out of
the equation the state does it
automatically you don't have to do
anything so anytime you do update your
address say with the DMV office even if
you don't also take the additional step
of registering or filling out the form
the state will do it for you and then
they'll send you a postcard saying
you've now been registered if for every
reason you want to opt out now you can
and what this does the results show does
it register so many more people or again
the first state to do it registered over
a hundred thousand new voters and many
of these people turned out to vote that
probably otherwise wouldn't have had the
opportunity to vote yeah that was gonna
be my next question which is the second
order question is does someone who is
automatically registered rather than
choosing to do it are they actually more
likely to go and vote and it sounds like
some of the data says that yes they are
yeah in fact you know a recent study
looked at turnout rates between the
different states in the 2018 midterm
election and showed that states with
either automatic voter registration or
for Saint in day registration can show
up to the polls and vote at the same
time had the highest turnout levels and
the stage with registration deadlines of
30 days or three weeks before the
election had the lowest turnout levels
so these reforms really work and again
they're implemented in a positive
fashion in a handful of states already
now it is possible to play devil's
advocate that states that have these
sort of automatic registration methods
are states that for other reasons
already have fostered sort of a more
engaged voting public and that it's not
necessarily because of the automatic
registration but I think we don't need
to necessarily get into it at that level
here it seems pretty clear that states
that have a certain philosophy on voting
do have voter turnout maybe for a
variety of reasons would be fair to say
well I'd push back on the question of or
the notion that states that already have
engaged voters are doing this because
you look at you know West Virginia which
third state to adopt automatic voter
registration or Georgia a state that has
had many voting woes and they have
automatic
registration so this is you know you
asked about the low-hanging fruit this
is because it's already working in a lot
of places so you mentioned or I mean I
guess we're talking about this in the
context of we have 50 states and
different states handle this issue and
voting in general very differently are
there states right now that you've
identified that sort of in general would
get like an a on voter access and voter
enfranchisement yeah it would be
Colorado Colorado has I think the best
voting mechanism when it comes to
Election Day itself it has essentially a
combination of Universal vote by mail
also known as a vote at home and vote
centers so on Universal vote by mail
states the state automatically mails
everyone about about two or three weeks
before Election Day whether they've
requested it or not so it's not like
absentee balloting or you have to ask
for it it doesn't automatically you may
not even know an election is about to
take place so you can sit at home and
fill it out and research the issues in
the candidates so that leads to a more
informed engaged electorate and then
drop it off with a secure drop box or
mail it in and you don't do that if you
want to vote on Election Day if you need
some sort of assistance the state has
vote centers which means that instead of
having to go to a home based precinct at
a polling place closest to your home
address you can go to any vote center in
the county and they're all
electronically connected so once you
check into one you can't check into
another and the ballot that gets printed
is about four your home address
and so this is the ultimate in
convenience and voting this combination
of automatically receiving a ballot but
then if you really want to go to your
polling place or a polling place you can
go to any vote center in your County as
well so on the other side which states
are the worst as far as this goes well
any of the states that have a 30-day
registration deadline Texas with its
continued woes in addition to that its
strict voter ID requirements that really
don't have any benefit in reducing fraud
and yet disenfranchise a handful a good
number of people certain constituencies
any of the states that don't have this
kind of convenience factor in voting and
we see it in the voter
not numbers so I'm originally from
Argentina and in Argentina we have
what's called mandatory voting which
basically means unless you demonstrate
that you're living outside of the
country like I am for example or unless
you have some health reason or other
reason for not participating and you've
sort of presented that to the state you
are expected to vote and can be fined or
otherwise punished if you don't what's
your sense generally from a
philosophical standpoint about mandatory
voting and then from a logistical
standpoint is it actually something that
would be be desirable because choosing
not to vote if you're doing so freely
although I'm not in favor of that as a
strategy it is something people can do
to show displeasure with the system it
is still a conscious decision people can
make yes so Argentina has that Australia
has mandatory voting would turnout of
over 90 percent and you know this leads
to it seems like a pretty engaged
informed electorate and so
philosophically I think anything we can
do to encourage participation while
coupled with improved civics education
is a good idea now do I think this is
likely or possible in the United States
no I think philosophically people are
against it although I'll note that in
any mandatory voting system you would
have to have an option essentially for I
don't like any of the bums and so the
requirement is to show up not
necessarily to choose one of the
candidates but I do think that if we
adopted all the reforms that I mentioned
in the book thanks to these everyday
Americans who are champing them in their
local communities then we would get to
something a lot closer to universal
turnout you know I have it at the end of
the book I say why not aspire to
something like 90 percent turnout that
seems crazy during in our current
environment and given the numbers of 60%
turnout in presidential elections
you know 2018 midterms had 50 percent
turnout and we were celebrating that
high voter engagement it was a record
and I thought you know if half the
electorate isn't showing up why are we
celebrating yeah I think right to
something like 90% and
we make it part of the way then we'll be
doing a lot better so I guess the next
sort of layer of discussion that seems
relevant is you outline a lot of these
reforms and you talk about as you call
them democracy champions that at local
levels are actually activating to try to
get some of some of these reforms
enacted but there is to some degree this
kind of vicious circle where the voting
system we have is determined in great
part by the people that are representing
us that are our elected officials those
are people who have benefited from the
system we have insofar as they've gotten
elected under it and so in great part
they may not actually be motivated to
make the changes that you're describing
so what are the actual activist actions
what which pieces of this do just
activists have control and power over
and which parts actually require first
voting some different people into office
well it really depends on the state law
and the ability of voters to have doubt
propositions whether is for local
elections or statewide elections you
look at a place like Michigan that had
horrible partisan gerrymandering in the
way it draws its lines and the state
just passed a state constitutional
amendment to implement an independent
Redistricting Commission to draw the
lines the next time we do this starting
in 2021
so Michigan voters had the opportunity
and ability to pass about proposition
requiring that in other states that's
not possible and then again we talk
about local laws some states give their
localities what's known as home rule or
essentially authority to have local
specific laws for their local elections
and you see a lot of movement in places
like Maryland in California in Tennessee
we've seen some successes for local
reforms so it really is location
specific but here's what I'd say is that
let's make the efforts and implement the
actions in the places where it is
legally possible because that creates an
evidence that creates a body of evidence
to show to the other states hey this
actually works to improve turnout to get
into gaming much more engaged informed
electorate and it's not a partisan power
grab it's simply a democracy Tyra Graham
can this discussion be separated from
the
discussion about how politics is
financed in the United States or are
these really related issues that have to
be dealt with in tandem well I think the
financing of politics is its own
separate issue to reform it but of
course also informs the you know the
ability to make a lot of these other
changes but I have a separate chapter on
campaign finance reform and specifically
public financing and what some places
like Maine and Seattle are doing to
improve the access of ability for people
to run for office so I think it's both a
separate issue as well as something that
works in tandem with all these other
reforms and kind of in parallel with
that I'm curious whether you see the way
in which at least at the presidential
level we have this electoral college
system I mean is that something that you
think plays into the reforms you're
talking about or or is that more of a
separate issue
well I think the electoral college plays
into the voter apathy concern that
involves so many of our elections and
you know one reason that people don't
vote is they feel like it's not gonna
make a difference and why bother I mean
you know if you're a Republican in
California or a Democrat in Texas you
think that you know the result is
essentially preordained in the electoral
college but that said there's also a
reform possible for the electoral
college itself that I talked about
briefly towards the end of the book and
this is the national popular vote
interstate compact for essentially
states are agreeing that instead of
awarding their electoral college votes
to whoever wins their state they'll
award it to the national popular vote
winner and that's really gaining steam
as well yep that we've actually talked
about that quite a bit and of course
until there are enough states whose sum
total of electors totals 270 it doesn't
get triggered but a number of states and
I don't remember it but it for some
reason I think it's 12 or 13 is that
right I've said it's maybe 12 plus DC
now that's a very interesting initiative
which we will we'll keep talking about
we've been speaking with Josh Douglas
who's a law professor at the University
of Kentucky about his book vote for us
how to take back our elections and
change the future of voting Josh really
a pleasure having you on today thank you
so much this has been fun